well what i'd like to talk to you about
today is a symbol that is fairly
ill-defined i mean it's not like little
e for the electron charge but it's a big
capital n
and i i think we use capital n n refers
to number and the capital refers to
a big number so i'd like to talk about
some really big numbers now it's
interesting we've all got very familiar
with big numbers
as a result of the collapse of the
banking systems and the incompetence of
governments and so on so for example
finance ministers now talk about
borrowing
hundreds of billions of dollars or
hundreds of billions of pounds so we're
all familiar with even with the idea of
a trillion pounds and a trillion of
course is
let me write it down a trillion
is one with 12 zeros after it
i'll have to go to another line
so that's a trillion
so
for convenience rather than writing out
all these notes we say that this uh
trillion with its 1 and 12 notes we
write that as
10 to the power 12 and that's a pretty
impressive number now interestingly
this is only a little bit larger than
the number of stars in our galaxy so
when these politicians
are talking about borrowing sums they
are literally talking about
astronomically large numbers
and what i'd like to talk about today
are numbers which are even larger than
that
perhaps the the first one to discuss is
big n with
a little subscript and this subscript
commemorates an italian physicist and
chemist called
lorenzo avogadro
now avogadro's number tells us how many
atoms or molecule
molecules that we have in a small lump
of material and uh the
the lump of material we measure in terms
of grams we don't use old british
imperial or american units of of ounces
and pounds we use gram so we define the
idea of a gram molecule and a gram
molecule
is just uh
let me give you an example for the case
of carbon carbon has got
an atomic weight of 12
that means that it's got six protons and
six neutrons and protons and neutrons
have got got about the same mass and we
say the atomic weight of carbon is 12.
so then we say that one gram molecule
of carbon weighs 12 grams
and then if we use that idea of a gram
molecule then one gram molecule of
carbon contains avogadro's number worth
of carbon atoms and that number very
roughly it's 6.02 if i remember
correctly but perhaps i'll just write it
as 6. that's then given by 6 times 10 to
the 23.
so there's that
we'll be writing 2 as a power but if i
want to write that out in longhand i'm
now going to put down 6 and 23 notes so
i've got to put down 6.
and now i can stop so i think now i've
got six and 23 zeros so that's how many
atoms of carbon there are in 12 grams of
charcoal
my favorite number all is this number
which is at 10 to the power of 40. now
do you really want me to write out the
40 zeros for this one i will if you like
right all right then
i'm nearly there aren't i
36 39 40. yep done it so there's the
number it's a really big number
now that number
is has got the symbol of just big n and
i think it's a fascinating number uh
dirac
one of the great heroes of quantum
mechanics
was also
interested in these large numbers and he
came up with his so-called large number
hypothesis which i'd like to tell you
about
that there are two important things in
physics that that
that have this have this correspond to
this very very large number and one of
them
is the strength of the electrical force
so i can write that the electrical force
f e over the force of gravity
corresponds to this so let's imagine now
that we've got a negatively charged
electron and a positively charged proton
the electron has mass and the proton has
mass and so because these two particles
have mass they're attracted to each
other but because they've got opposite
charges they're also attracted to each
other by
the force by electrical forces by
coulomb's law
and in fact this ratio
is about 10 to the 40.
so the electrical force is
that much stronger
than the gravitational force
this ratio is comparable with
roughly the age of the universe and the
time it takes uh
a photon traveling at the speed of light
to to cross
uh the
diameter of of this proton now it's
perfectly real reasonable for me to put
a magnifying magnifying glass on this
proton
has got a radius it's very very small
and it's given by 10 to the minus 15
meters so that's the radius of a proton
now that's small and of course
the light travels a tremendously fast
speed of 3 times ten to the eight meters
per second so a photon can shoot across
this diameter in a very short interval
of time
then
we can relate that very short time to
the longest time that we know about
which of course the longest time we can
conceive of is the age of the universe
and we know that the age of the universe
is 13.7 billion years
which is 13.7 000 million years so
that's a very long time and this is an
incredibly short time at the age of the
universe is about 10 to the 17 seconds
and then if we divide that by the time
it takes the photon to cross the new to
cross a proton
and lo and behold
10 to the 17 divided by this very small
number gives me 10 to the 40.
so we've got the ratio of these two
times uh being approximately equal and
it led it led directly
very very interesting but as it turned
out wrong idea that these numbers were
fundamentally uh related to each other
this this this this strange coincidence
was was was finally sorted out and i'd
like to tell you how the paradox was
sorted out by a very clever guy from
princeton a guy called
robert dickey and
this coincidence really isn't a
coincidence at all for the following
reason what dickie noted was
that the laws of physics the electrical
forces and the gravitational forces are
important in determining the lifetime of
stars
so if it happened that the gravitational
force was much much stronger
then stars would be more compact objects
they would burn their nuclear fuel more
quickly and stars wouldn't live so long
we we are here observing the universe at
its present age
and
therefore this is a rather special
situation in because you know we're
around to observe the present age of the
universe but for us to be around to
observe the age of the universe certain
requirements must be met and amongst
those requirements
uh are that
that we're made of things not just of
hydrogen but of things like phosphorus
and
carbon most importantly so what dickey
realized was that in order for us to be
around to notice this interesting
coincidence
there must have been several life cycles
of stars
in other words the universe has to be at
least as old as the age of a star and
probably is the age of several stars so
what what what dickie realized was that
the fact that the age of the universe as
we presently observe it is simply a
consequence of the laws of physics
as applied to stars and therefore
these two numbers are just
just
a consequence of the anthropic principle
if you like that we're around to observe
uh
as observer unit the universe has to be
this old for observers to be around in
another 10 to the 40 zillion trillion
years if humans are still around
that coincidence won't be the case
anymore will it no it won't it will
change as the universe gets older but
other but but on those very very long
time scales i mean other things will
will happen i mean you know the our sun
will burn out by then and
uh so either unless unless we go and
colonize some other other star a planet
around a star then
we won't be around won't be around to
observe that now there is an even bigger
number a couple of other bigger numbers
that come from this which which also
fascinates me if you as i mentioned
already if you take the square of this
number and this this gives you the 10 to
the 80 10 to the 80
is approximately equal to the number of
protons in the universe so i'll write
proton there
and
the number of protons in the universe is
roughly that size as well
so that's another interesting large
number and i'm not going to bother to
write out 80 zeros but that's that's
another story and a fascinating one
what do your colleagues think about this
do they enjoy this like the way you do
well i guess so yeah they i go on too
much of this in the tea room they think
i'm a bit crazy talking about large
numbers so i think about them as a bit
of a hobby i want to be spending more
time doing something gonna have to visit
physics